what's
your favorite esport cs go
league of legends ballarant whatever it
is i bet it's watched by
millions of other fans around the world
and is considered one of the big ones
well today we're going to be looking at
the little ones
those small and improbable esports that
seem like they
just shouldn't work but they do and
it's amazing so let's dive down the
peculiar rabbit hole that is
the top 10 weirdest esports
plowing into number 10 is the highly
competitive world
of wait for it farming simulator
welcome everyone we are here at class
and has wrinkled where 26 teams made it
to the qualifiers but only eight will
fight for the very first
fsl tournament win it's the game that
simulates farming
you harvest crops to buy better farming
equipment to harvest more crops
exciting stuff it seems like the last
place you'd find competition and yet in
2019
fans of the game were treated to the
first ever farming
simulator league
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my god upset there we go they did it
who did just about that came down to the
last fail
i hope you didn't fall off your chairs
there the rules in the farming simulator
league are simple
two teams of three are given a field of
wheat and 15 minutes to turn it into
bales and
get them into the barn four points just
like mainstream esports there's picks
and bands
unique perks trophies and the meta is
actually pretty complex
going for the increased uh
the decreased wheat price and that was
interesting and it
i think it counts as a lot of the
current tactics because all teams go for
the
pretty much the same late game we wait
for that two minute window and then just
push out 400 points tactic
and if you really need proof that this
is an
esport check out this clutch last minute
hay bale play from the last farming
simulator league
finals is there enough time for those
bails to get up there i don't think
there is
no there is not i think five seconds
four seconds eight twenty seven seventy
that it is
trello borg is the world champion they
made it
they are the champions
every day we stray further from god at
number nine we have
shrek super slam otg
you can keep your tekken your street
fighter your smash bros for a small
community out there
2005 shrek super slam is the
ultimate fighting game the shrek
universe was resurrected from its pop
culture death
thanks to a generation of zoomers making
memes about the classics they grew up on
push push push into that tunnel nice job
get to the back side of this jump andrea
hang in there
but a group of dedicated shrek spurts
turn the memes into
reality by mastering a game that was
never meant to be more than a shrek
mania cash-in
it may have started out as a joke but it
snowballed into a community who takes
the game as
seriously as any other fighting game
well almost as seriously boy gets a
combo
that's a word i'm instantly pressing
that as a sign that they're here to stay
the community recently released a
remastered version of the game in hd
quality so that no slam goes unmissed
it's glitchy it's unbalanced and it's
unlikely to get within a mile of evo's
main stage but the people who love shrek
super slam
really love it and they're just fine
with the way things are
let's go someone call my mom because i
think i just found her spaghetti
shredding into number eight we have
clone hero
wow that is a 5k 6k difference
george successfully baiting randy into
the follow up
as the name might suggest clone hero is
almost an exact replica of guitar hero
with the freedom to modify the game how
they wanted it didn't take long for fans
to develop tournaments using the
multiplayer mode
five fret esports laid the groundwork as
the first
major tournament and was soon followed
by the csc
championship series this featured some
big names in the scene a clean layout to
see competitors scores
and some pretty hyped casting oh my
goodness
at the very end oh my goodness
no no that's still not enough that's
still not enough
two thousand diffusion diffusion
saves it the buzz has now reached a
point where people are asking
could this actually become a major
esport
c9 versus g2 on clone hero anyone
at number seven we've got a game with
perhaps the least esports name
imaginable catherine isn't even going
for the the first the one
okay the drop
kick the u.s dropkick samurai yeah
getting it on reno
going down for that at its core
catherine is a single-player puzzle game
set in the tormented dreams of a
heartbroken man torn between
two women but the game also contains a
best-of-three
multiplayer mode which is a race to the
top of a tower
navigated by pulling and pushing blocks
players who took a deeper look at this
mode found it to be
far deeper than you might expect
to try to stop him but he does end up
getting up but he still doesn't have an
easy climb here whoa that's a big play
by shot
perfectly you can win by reaching the
top of the tower or by killing your
opponent
the intricacy bred and meta which
birthed the competitive scene we see
[Applause]
shaz is your champion
next up at number six we've got a stone
cold
classic in the form of age of empires 2.
oh the revenge trap are you kidding me
are you kidding me now it's not strange
that age of empires 2 has a competitive
scene
it's a beloved rts game with multiplayer
built in
many people have childhood memories of
playing their friends on lan
what is weird though is that for a game
that's over 23 years old
the esports scene is pretty big over 50
000 people tuned in on twitch to watch
the hidden cup 3 finals
even if you've never played the game
before it's hype as
[ __ ] players are simply scared running
into demos right that's
the potential place where we could lose
the game
oh oh my god he got two demos three
scouts and six crossbows they're
not showing the exact number but that
was a huge demo from alert you called
that one nilly
it's growing by the day even when the
old game throws up some glitches
okay okay look at this thanks to e
the candles caught in the house man
at the number five spot we have the game
that nobody asked for
shaq fu shaquille o'neal may be known to
millions as an nba hall of famer but to
some
he's simply the face of shaq fu the 1994
fighting game that was almost
universally hated
upon release shack foo just the name
makes people cringe
like you don't even want to go there
it's been panned by critics as
over animated and clunky at best and
just
boring at worst all of this makes it
even more incredible that people play
this game competitively
one of the highlights has to be where a
man called
horseface killer took home the first
place prize of paxis 2013
and while some esports have millions of
dollars in prize money the ceo 2018
shaq food champion received a coveted
golden shack food
cartridge yes that's jealousy you're
feeling right now
on your bikes now for number four we
have zwift
james is trying to come across but it
looks like it's gonna be said and done
for the overall
james phillips previously that's the
line it looked like for the win in this
race
but cam jeffers i think just won a
national championship
zwift is a game where players ride
real-life training bikes to cycle
through a
virtual world this does prompt the
question
why not just go outside and cycle while
some may debate about swiss title
as an esport the races are physically
impressive which helps draw
thousands of viewers to these events but
of course no esport
is complete without a scandal the zwift
scene was shaken
to its very core when british champion
cameron jeffers
used a bot to unlock one of the fastest
bikes
in the game and was banned from racing
to unlock
the tron bike you have to climb 50 000
meters on on zwift of elevation so
um basically this person just set my
avatar on alters worth going up and down
out zwift which is like the biggest
virtual climb in the game and before
long i had completed the 50 000 meter
challenge and my avatar had unlocked the
trombike
the fact that the bikes aren't
standardized is weird enough but you can
even use
in-game power-ups that are distributed
randomly throughout your race
tequila the power-up being used consumer
used there by the south africa of the
power-up
on nearly the steepest part of the climb
and rob she's moving clear
half a second clear now she is now
whether or not you think zwift is an
esport
the zwifters certainly do so don't be
surprised if you hear
more from them in the future it's
osborne who's gonna be the world
champion for the first time in esports
a trendsetter and germany have it
blasting into number three we have blast
on
now at first glance blast on is a simple
vr
game two players face off in a duel
using futuristic weapons to
knock down each other's health i think
how we both with silent mode right there
because we're focusing yeah this is a
game that's kind of hard to do
commentary for
it is the uniqueness of the weapons adds
a tactical layer to the game though
players need to know when to use them
and how to counter them
all while dodging their opponent's shots
looking i want to throw a quick
shield task did a damage already so gone
i want to throw it back
we're like nope nope nope okay dodge
both laser
uh dash the top pallet dash the sniper
dodge the shield tournaments have
already popped up but
in october 2020 blaston's owners said
they would like to see the game's
esports scene
develop into something like smash bros
can you
imagine this evo
wow moving on to number two
we have the sims yes as in
the sims in july 2020 ea partnered with
e-league and buzzfeed to produce the
sims
sparked a series which followed 12
contestants and a panel of judges
as they faced off in this classic game
that was
never meant to be competitive and
it was pretty weird each team will have
a stylist
builder and a storyteller a stylist
creates the
character known as sims the builder
designs the worlds
and the storyteller brings it all to
life by producing a dynamic narrative
eleague is known for putting on
tournaments for cs go
street fighter and overwatch so this was
quite a departure for them
nancy had heard old wives tales that a
spellcaster named amethyst
who lived in el salvadorata had the
power to restore
youth this story is incredible
despite e-league's involvement the 100k
prize pool and the fact that the show
referred to the players as
pro-sims players the competitive sim
scene didn't really take off after this
but you know it makes much more sense if
you just enjoy it as a good old reality
show
his daughter wants to go to a concert
but you know they're living on a
fisherman's
budget so the dad the fisherman dad
is gonna put on a concert for his
daughter
and finally at number one we have geo
guesser
um wow four nine nine nine points
very good information to go on there now
i
love geoguessr if you haven't played it
before it uses google maps to drop you
in a random part of the world
and you have to guess where you are the
closer your guess is on the map the more
points you get
only 10 seconds left i'm still not sure
if gc
actually saw an error code i know he's
seen a couple phone numbers
chicago with the very last second
adjustment moves himself
very close uh compared to where he was
the geographer esports channel features
some of the best geoguesses in the world
facing off in five round matches most
points at the end wins
it's probably the most chilled out
esport you'll ever see
and the casting definitely reflects that
it seems the camera is also a bit
wet going this direction as opposed to
going north where the camera isn't quite
as bad
watching a game you can even see the
beginnings of a
meta evolving for example don't be a
scrub who clicks
uphill yeah it has something to do with
just the way the
the clicking works in street view if
you're going downhill you can see
further
and click a little bit farther than if
you're going uphill
well guys those were certainly weird but
weird doesn't always mean bad
which one of those was your favorite
which one of those has the potential to
become
a major esport let me know and also on
your way out the door
don't forget to subscribe if you haven't
done so already thanks for watching guys
and i'll see you all in the next one
when i saw the line where you said i
love geoguess here it's like dude i
actually
love geo guesser like i play that [ __ ]
all the time do you ever watch geo
wizard it it
it's insane the stuff that he notices
like
he'll notice like a bumper sticker that
they just for some reason they only have
that bumper sticker in nigeria
and he just knows that that that's gotta
be esport-worthy
that's that's so big the skill ceiling
is huge